mientras el reloj corre a toda velocidad
para finalizar está con 26 considerada o
lo que se espera sea un punto de
inflexión para el planeta el secretario
general de la onu alertó hoy que los
países deben ser mucho más ambiciosos y
que ese objetivo de mantener controlada
la temperatura del planeta en 1.5 grados
está en cuidados intensivos y también
pidió acabar con los recursos
millonarios para financiar la industria
de los hidrocarburos
justamente y como un tema pendiente para
salvar el planeta en toda esta carrera
hoy costa rica y dinamarca presentaron
la alianza más allá del petróleo y del
gas que reúne por el momento a otros 10
países incluidos francia y otras
ciudades para empezar paulatinamente a
acabar con la producción de
hidrocarburos e incluso se contempla que
se van a parar de darles xxi a licencias
para explotar los hidrocarburos y
también para explorar nuevos campos en
ese territorio es cierto que los países
firmantes no son los grandes productores
de petróleo pero hoy han dado un paso en
esa dirección correcta en ese asunto
pendiente y han expresado su voluntad
política por avanzar en esta materia y
así lo ha expresado la ministra de
medioambiente de costa rica- andrea meza
quien ha dicho que sí es cierto que son
los primeros pero que son los primeros
valientes edad en dar en ese paso
justamente hoy la cop se ha enfocado en
tratar la importancia de las ciudades
cómo lograr que reduzcan sus emisiones
porque se considera que el 40 por ciento
de las emisiones globales son generadas
por las ciudades por las viviendas por
la infraestructura en éstas por ello la
importancia de lograr esa transición
para incluso medios de transporte mucho
más amigables con el medio ambiente el
gobierno británico anunció hoy recursos
por 27 millones de libras esterlinas
para ayudar a países en desarrollo entre
ellos territorios en américa latina'
como bogotá medellín guadalajara ciudad
de mexico y lima